[THEME MUSIC]
EMILY FORTUNA: Here with
us now is Harsh Kharbanda,
product manager on Lens.
Welcome, Harsh.
HARSH KHARBANDA: Hi, Emily.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Harsh, there
were so many AR announcements
at I/O. Let's go a little
deeper with one of them--
Lens and Google Go.
Can you take us back to when you
all were first conceiving it?
What were the problems that
you were trying to solve?
HARSH KHARBANDA: Sure.
So technology is getting
cheaper and more accessible.
Smartphones today can
cost as little as $50.
And while building all our
OCR and document instruction
understanding
capabilities in Lens,
we realized that these can
be transformational for users
new to smartphones.
There's two things that
we realized about users
who are new to smartphones.
The first thing is that
the smartphone is likely
their first digital device.
Unlike you and I, they haven't
grown up with desktops.
And so the keyboard itself
is a novel concept for them.
They have to learn
how to express
information needs for the first
time on a 2-inch keyboard.
And typing is just
fundamentally hard.
The second thing we realized was
that these users typically have
lower literacy rates, which
means that they come across
text throughout their lives--
bank forms, ATM notices,
street signs--
text that they want to
understand, but really
have to depend on
others to do so.
But the camera is something
everybody knows how to use.
The selfie has really made
its way around the world.
So we thought, what if we
could build a camera that
could help you
learn, understand,
and read the world around you.
And that's what we did
with Lens and Google Go.
EMILY FORTUNA:
That's super cool.
I first see myself making use
of Google Go when I travel,
for example.
It's like, if I don't know
a language or the alphabet,
it's like I have my own
personal translator.
Can you tell us
about the first time
you saw someone use Lens
how you had envisioned?
HARSH KHARBANDA: Sure.
So we've been testing
Lens and Google Go
over the past several months.
And we've seen people use it
in several different instances
throughout their daily lives--
bank forms, ATM notices,
product packages,
medicine labels.
But the point where
we realized we
were making a true impact
on the users' lives
was when we saw a parent
using Lens and Google Go
on their child's homework to
understand what the homework
problem was and help
them in their education.
Before that, the
homework was in English.
The parent could not
really help the child.
But in this case, they were
able to take a picture,
translate it into the
language that they understood,
and understand the problem
and be really a part
of their child's education.
And that is something
that's really
humbling and gratifying to see.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Harsh, that
sounds really awesome, and also
fairly complex.
Can you tell us about some
of the technical challenges
that you faced
while building this?
HARSH KHARBANDA: Yeah.
So to be able to
do all of this, we
had to bring the
technology to a phone
that new smartphone users
would be able to afford.
And so we had to bring OCR
to be able to understand
the text that users take a
picture of-- machine learning
to translate the text
into the language
that these users
speak, TTS to be
able to read it out in a
very naturally accented form.
And even AR to highlight each
word as it's being read out.
All of that is done on a phone
that costs as little as $50
and an APK footprint
of 100 kilobytes.
And that was a really hard
technical challenge for us.
EMILY FORTUNA: Harsh, thank you
so much for joining us today.
HARSH KHARBANDA:
Thank you, Emily.
[THEME MUSIC]